right now she is a fifth generation
ukrainian canadian and for heather
foisie those roots run deep this was
actually near my bomb shelter where i
stayed over watching the news feeds it's
just heartbreaking watching what these
people are going through and while she
doesn't have any family in the country
today she's cried more tears for the
people there than she's willing to admit
it's been an emotional rollercoaster of
ups and downs between anxiety depression
this feeling of hopelessness and she
decided to do something about it she
reached out on facebook and connected
with a mother who fled ukraine with her
young son and now foisey and her family
are preparing to welcome them into their
home we've already set our son phoenix
down and let him know that we're going
to be hosting a family and he's excited
to be able to help
we are getting google translate onto all
of our devices deeply stirred sabrina
stetsko has had her home prepared for a
ukrainian family for weeks now she's
also created a podcast and a network on
facebook hoping to connect new arrivals
with resources and community many are
arriving traumatized with
they lost everything in in addition
loved ones and even pets uh so you know
there's a lot going on and so this would
be a way for everyone locally to just
come together airbnb says so far 24 000
people around the world including 750
canadians have offered their properties
free of charge or at very discounted
rates to ukrainians seeking somewhere to
live canada is home to many ukrainians
and many people of ukrainian descent and
i think what we're seeing is that sense
of kindness and that sense of community
stretch from coast to coast to coast
it's just a simple act of kindness
people helping people in unimaginable
crisis according to heather foisy
providing a safe space for a mother and
her son
has also given her a sense of purpose
during a conflict unfolding a world away
i know that it's only one action but
many people that are doing this is going
to be able to help
help many families jb doll global news
calgary